it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what's up guys welcome to screen
junkies movie fights I'm your guest host
Joe star your 25th favorite screen
junkie Hal Rudnick is not hosting today
for reasons we'll get into in just a
moment today we've got a great show
we're talking Guardians we're visiting
the 100 Acre Wood we're gonna go kill a
kid named smalls in a baseball field for
a minute it's gonna be a great show
not just because of those topics but
because of this panel the fighters let's
look at him jte oh my god about it
fighting today don't you host this show
you know what usually I do but I decided
to strap on the gloves and get in that
rocket and fly right to the MA I just
like that you host the show every week
and I don't know that you know what it
is man you know what I'll just say one
thing in the words of nada as portrayed
by rowdy roddy piper and john
carpenter's they live i came here to
kick ass and chew bubblegum and I'm all
out of bubble welllook in the words of
not a surf you're popular Thank You ed
green ladies and gentlemen from the
nobody who goes to specific places to
chew gum all right anyway and I was up
with a cavity search for the speed round
I just wanted to diminish that but I I
love you guys I'm very happy to be here
a look at this panel of fighters and I'm
very humbled this is gonna be a very
calm show today unless this lady starts
roughing things up you know her from
fandom you know her from the Schmo down
she's a killer over there Clark Wolfe
welcome thank you for having me I'm very
excited to be here this is gonna be a
good one we'll look I'm glad this is a
very very calm show cuz our first round
is gonna be very chilling on
controversial topic but before we get
there how's the show work these guys are
going to be shouting about a bunch of
very important movie topics probably
some of the most important things you're
going to hear about maybe this month
maybe in your life I'll be judging them
but I'm not alone I have help from the
dance dan Marone Daniel Radford hey guys
hello how are you Danny over there
checking facts I'm already checking my
first fact of the day Joe what's your
first back button my first fact of the
day and this is maybe the most misquoted
quote on the Internet is the the
verbatim quote from they live is I have
come here to chew bubblegum and kick ass
and I'm all out of bubblegum there are
many variations on such it's almost like
played against Sam I think the wrong
version is more popular than the yeah
what came here to eat Laffy Taffy and
engage in fisticuffs yes that's one of
my bootleg shirt the people Daniel
Radford hello I am back to being non
cussing Daniele because I'm not fighting
today this is put your gun little way
yeah it's a pg-13 Daniele and yes I am
the voice of the people I only vote my
own votes once we start getting to the
speed round
but until then y'all are gonna help me
by voting on the poll on YouTube there
are some really fun polls on Twitter
please participate those are great but
the only one that counts for this is the
one that is on YouTube click down in the
description if you want to hear about
how that works or if your feet to like
ask some questions in the chat cuz we're
gonna be in there monitoring it and we
can tell you how to get that going as
well also don't forget to tweet me any
relief fun things I can't say the other
thing it feels wrong without how at the
host but it feel fun feel free to send
me anything really fun on Twitter
because I'm gonna be reading a bunch of
those as well sounds good sounds good
Center some corgis and some dank memes
there we go that's right that's right I
like this reaching across that okay guys
here's how it works it's a best-of-seven
game a player needs four points total
both through the main round and the
speed round to win in the event of a one
1-1 tie or a 3.0 just complete ass kick
and go into the speed round I'll just
pick who I like the most
JK will do a tiebreaker round which will
not count towards the final score it'll
just count who goes towards the speed
round secret we chose this a month ago
cuz the show is rigged guys enough talk
jte I've waited my entire life to say
this roll that sick ass package
it's main event time
it's a solid package oh yeah solids on
the packaging guys and just out of the
corner maker just a rice of Lee grumble
karate kid' I don't know what all right
guys let's get into this round one I
think the day happened with James gun
out is director who should direct
guardians of the galaxy volume three
just a real chill question to kick off
the shot just really remember how a
minute ago everybody is really calm and
just happy to be here let's throw some
of that out the window so guys
everybody's got some feelings on the
James gun situation we've been pretty
loud about them on sju and if you want
to hear a lot of those feelings you
should be watching sju even for just
other reasons and James gun it's a great
show and if you don't watch it what's
wrong with you fix that so a lot of
that's probably gonna come out in the
round a little bit but at the end of the
day I just got it we just got a judge
you on answering the question who would
be the best director to to pick up a
Guardians three movie deal deal yeah
everyone's fingers are crossed
now kick us off alright so I'm not gonna
say that I I'm not gonna go on record
saying I agree with the decision to uh
get James gun out of there but I will
agree to answer this question and I am
gonna there's a verbal thing on camera
already yeah you're on board okay I'm
gonna pick one of the great directors
working today who has not yet had that
first big theatrical film and I feel
like guardians 3 could be her ticket to
just mega stardom as a director I'm
going with Michelle Maclaren
she's probably the best director working
in television today and I will elaborate
on that and breakdown why I think she
would be an amazing addition to the MCU
stable of directors and she'd be a great
choice for guardians three solid first
pick Edie well I thought about this long
and hard and then I thought why are you
doing that it's very very obvious the
guy is in house and it is tyka wat et
who directed thor ragnarok which is
basically thor guardians you know I mean
it's very
it's very Guardians inspired it has a
lot of the different sort of take the
take on space where it's just a bunch of
quipping guys with you know guns on
their hips and weird cosmic weapons that
we're all having a good time so I really
think he could step right in and be a
good little soldier and get this movie
out of the way until they get their
stuff sorted out okay
YTD Clark yeah well I also if you
watched Stas Ju when we discussed this
you know that I feel very strongly about
this whole situation in that I don't
think we should be in it and James
should be directing vol 3 but that said
that was not our question and I like Hal
have agreed to answer this question so
you know when you find yourself in a
situation where your studio like Disney
and you have hired the right person for
the job but for some weird reason you've
got to fire them you've got to fire them
whether you're about to start production
or you're in production who you gonna
call Ron Howard yes I think that Ron
Howard America's Sweetheart should pick
up the mantle and direct guardians three
all right guys we got three solid
answers let's fight it out all right but
I gotta jump in on this Ron Howard is a
bad choice even morally because we
forget his days as a young guy his his
his abusive law-enforcement dad had a
drunk in the drunk tank at all times you
know it o P stands for opium I actually
disagree with Ron Howard right off the
bat with real reasons yes
because I mean he took over for solo and
he made it this kind of thickness inert
generic thing and that is guardians is
even more so this franchise with a
unique wild fun voice and to put someone
who's so staid and just like by number
let's talk about that with your
directing choice a lady who directs
austere told there's a serious drama
curious it's not a laughing a bunch
she's like she's like Zack Snyder with a
womb Guardians you know I've heard that
argument and I've heard that said about
her before she's directed Modern Family
she used to run episode I looked at
she's directed better call Saul
hilarious with dramedy it's not quite
comedy I see she's well aware of what
surpassed comedies on her resume and she
has directed so much more than that and
she I think she's the best choice not
just because she's directed all of like
some of the greatest epics and best
television so Breaking Bad Game of
Thrones the leftovers Westworld you name
it she has been trusted with like giving
the keys to the greatest shows on TV I
should die serious sad good and now
you're right no [ __ ] like I noted she
directed comedies so like one choose to
I have to say on behalf of Ron Howard
and just so you guys know the splash is
an American classic I mean can we all
agree that splashes laughs galore
addition in addition to that though Ron
Howard if you want and I think it's
clear that Disney does right in the
world then the upside down that we live
in if you want competent action jokes
that sort of land sometimes
Ron Howard is the person for you I'm not
gonna stop you
I'll help you jokes up man
sometimes he took all the personality
away from our beloved Han Solo do you
want him to do that with rocket and
Peter quill and the rest of the game he
does have to be helpful here this
seppuku that is happening right here I
get it and it's a political it's like
when you set yourself on fire I get it
but yours I you're setting yourself on
fire as well by picking by picking
Michelle because honestly she's so great
and if she if she had gotten her shot on
a Wonder Woman if patty Jenkins had had
a falling out or gotten too busy she
would have been a great choice she'd be
a great choice to bring some gravitas
and a little bit of humor to a -
superman zack snyder with whatever a
combat aside and she is warmer that's
why I said with him you know because
she's warmer than him she's warmer than
any of these DC directors including some
of the ones they're doing these other
movie James Wan even actually warmer
than him that's one of the reasons why
she was let go from Wonder Woman because
they said she wanted to make it too much
of a rollicking adventure whereas the
patty Jenkins kept it just a little bit
more austere let's talk a little bit
about Taika Waititi for a second because
I am love me some Taika Waititi I love
him and and I think that he was the
first director to really get Thor and I
think that that is why Ragnarok was so
special but let's be honest he's in team
four right now when is he going to slip
in and take the reins on a huge third
installment so brothers were in team cap
and then they became team everybody
because they're brothers you said Tiger
won't work on one thing is ridiculous
that's what I've got it under cutting
that successful the Russo brothers are
working on like all of those movies are
almost all times could be introduced
into the fraternity of people who work
on too much stuff Plus is is Tyco at et
gonna have the restraint to not put
himself in the movie and be another CGI
character we're
get a girlfriend or a boyfriend if he
wants a boyfriend voice by Taika Waititi
boom perfect casting run of the business
casting around Michelle Maclaren would
be great for a couple other reasons
she's working with Chris Pratt right now
on cowboy ninja Viking and they
everything seems to be going well with
that and that's an exciting project so
they're already gonna have this
connection and how amazing would it
would it be for Marvel to finally get a
female director into theirs hasn't been
one Anna Bowden is directing Captain
Marvel but we haven't seen any woman
direct Marvel films do we have to wait
until it's only a female centric
character until it's a Captain Marvel
until it's a Wonder Woman to bring a
woman on board to direct well I I don't
I don't think it's pick an Islander or a
woman in a diversity off like it's such
a small percentage of theatrical films
that are directed by women and is not
because of if she was hurting for work I
can understand that argument but she's
doing what she is is going to do and
she's expanding all the while like she's
starting a franchise why would she want
to come off of strength franchise she
started with Chris because she's a
director who likes to direct but to your
point why is it if we're going to hire a
woman to direct a movie that we have to
give her the one who finds itself
mysteriously vacated right now why is it
why can't we find the right person for
that movie what makes her aside from
being a woman and having a vacancy that
needs to be filled the right persons for
guardians of the galaxy's making your
final thoughts how I would make Michelle
Maclaren and the director of guardians
of the galaxy and I say she's the right
person for it because she can direct
action adventure like no one else if you
watch her track record on TV she has
earned the right to do that I would give
her this open job because she has earned
the right to do that by directing some
of the best episodes of Breaking Bad
Game of Thrones and
also directing major television comedies
she has this relationship with Chris
Pratt
and this I feel like after the second
guardians film which we it wasn't
definitely a different tone it was a
little bit murky as far as a lot of the
emotional stuff
I feel like guardians needs to get back
to that straight-up action-adventure
that we had in the first one and she is
the woman to make that happen
absolutely had final thoughts this is
the third movie in a series and while
the the epic nature of the second movie
kind of got a little muddled I feel like
the tone was remarkably consistent it
was definitely the same writer director
on both films now that we are being
denied that we have to I believe go with
much like when you're when you're
reading a comic book when Neal Adams or
draw a comic book and then leave who
would they get somebody who drew kind of
like Neal Adams to ease you in to the
replacement to ease you into that Taika
Waititi is the bill sick early bilkins
bill syncovich to the Neal Adams that is
James Gunn the styles are similar enough
and the actual attention to detail the
fact that Thor Ragnarok resembles Kirby
drawings on purpose because he went back
and looked at the cosmic world of Marvel
is just a bunch of Kirby drawings so he
decided to make he got Thor the very
first person to get Thor as a cosmic
character and he gets cosmic stuff
guardians of the galaxy is cosmic stuff
the definition of it he's already shown
that he gets it he's already shown the
ability to ape the style of the person
that's unfortunately being replaced that
is why he's the best person not murky
lady from TV and not protests Ron Howard
[Laughter]
listen American treasure Ron Howard can
get it done do you want to get a family
comedy like Parenthood done Col Ron
Howard do you want to get an
action-adventure movie like willow done
call Ron Howard do you want to reboot
your Han Solo character Allard if you
need to put somebody in the job who's
gonna get it done
who's gonna get a
with everyone and who's gonna pay really
close attention to all the things that
were done before and do it mostly like
that without any personality that's what
Watts so really in order to make sure
that everyone is satisfied there's no
one else but Ron Howard the facts are
pretty pretty solid everyone had had a
very good grasp on the film our
respective filmography zuv they're uh of
their different directors there was I I
did do some research into whether tyka
is indeed in a team Thor right now and
while he's not officially signed on
there have been reports that he said
discussions with there's a whole
question about Chris Hemsworth and
Avengers four and we don't know what's
gonna happen to the characters so you
know while he's not officially in
production there's been also discussions
potentially they've said between those
two about what could happen and so I'll
let that one slide even though there's
no official confirmation on that oh that
everyone had a very good grasp of there
was their respective opponents choices
well facts decide based on the arguments
Dan he's gonna get your vote today
I respect Clark's tactics it was a
protest vote more than anything however
I can't quite edge over to right she did
she did sort of make the case against
Ron Howard
I respect the creativity of it but when
I'm picking a winner it came down
between ed and Hal for me and I actually
thought how I've had some good knock
backs to what people they threw a lot at
him with Michelle Maclaren but
ultimately I don't quite think it was
enough particularly Clark's
counter-argument as to you know yes
there's an open job but why this movie
and why this director I didn't quite get
on board as well as I did with Ed's
arguments for Tycho ITV so I'm gonna go
with Edie okay one vote for Edie
Danielle what did the people have to say
um well so right now we don't know if
the people whose vote counts yet
because we've got to wait until the
other votes come in but oh that's right
I got to say something yeah you have to
get you a new vote but I will let you
know what the people what the people
vote and we'll find out after you vote
if it counts so overwhelmingly people
are going for Tiger ytt with 74%
Michelle Maclaren with 14% and Ron
Howard with a smooth 10% that sounds
about right
it's a bold strategy cotton okay
so first of all I wanted the the protest
argument was amazing too but I also want
to give a lot of props to Clark for just
going full low-key and sometimes she was
teaming up with an to kill howl and then
sometimes she was putting ed in a
sleeper hold
and sometimes she was I wasn't sure if
she still wanted to be on the show or
not and so Bravo cuz that was a that was
a hell of a first round between ed and
how IDI I loved your closing argument so
so much the the Neil Adams argument was
was phenomenal but it just it was it was
it came in just a little too late for me
whereas I thought how was really sort of
staying on top of everything you guys
threw at him so my vote is is how for
Michelle Maclaren
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
like Charlie Brown to all of this
[ __ ] about a year from now this same
group will get together on this set and
argue who should direct Guardians three
now that Lord and Miller have been right
always in forever Ron Howard
well we're about to get into it first
question - hey hmm I guess good things
to say let's go the 100 Acre Wood you
guys let's go question number two
Christopher Robin hits theaters this
weekend what Disney movie should get a
thirty years later sequel what Disney
movie should get a thirty years later
sequel Alex Trebek is retiring I'm
auditioning like he always repeats the
question that could second more none say
at a time and I'm just working on it
Edie what you got this was rough for me
because if there if I do have a nerd
blind spot
it is definitely Disney movies but I
have yeah
so I watched a movie recently though and
I think it might have been one of the
better movies I've ever seen period and
I really loved it I would love to see it
30 years later sequel for it and it is
Moana I would love to see it 30 years
later a sequel of Moana she's supposed
to be between 14 and 16 I do believe
this instead in the Canon that she's 16
in this movie and and
and Maui is a Island demigod that she
hangs out with and she has a rig great
adventure where she like return
something that was taken and that is
what disperses the evil so I would think
that 30 year and she returned her people
to a seafaring race that went out on the
sea and then always knew their way back
so they would go adventure instead of
just staying in their coal that would go
adventure well I figure if she's made
them sort of nomadic see people maybe on
their way back their way is barred by a
new group of Islanders or maybe
Outlanders if we want to go ahead and be
you know talking some historical jazz
you know and the whole story would be
about her and her daughter trying to
overcome this new group of people maybe
beside ins Raiders or something I don't
know ocean dudes that are that are on
the attack right now and that would be
kind of the basis of it her as a mother
maybe even grandmother and what her
story is and what her daughter or
granddaughter story is now sort of a
passing of the torch I dig it
Carly you know that that is a very very
good answer but it's not the best answer
I'm about to hit you with the best
answer so as we all know Disney has
recently acquired a little brand called
Lucasfilm
and in that treasure trove of Lucasfilm
lies a classic and I'm not kidding
directed by Ron Howard my answer is
willow willow needs of 30 years later
sequel Willow was not as appreciated
during its time as it should have been
and I got to tell you I watched this
movie probably a little too much but it
is aged so well so we pick up with a
Laura Dannon a different kind of Disney
Princess she's like you know a newborn
here so she would be about 30 and we see
what's happening with her we see what's
happening to the kingdom that she is now
ruling over we see what happened magmar
Deegan and sorsha are they still
together are they not do they have kids
because remember at the end of willow
they adopted a Laura Dannon after they
defeated bath Merida and something tells
me that Queen have more
wasn't gonna go quietly she like melts
into all this misty stuff but she could
easily come back we got magic happening
here plus let's not forget our titular
character willow willow off good where
is he what has he been up to you see the
great wizard that he always should have
been
we'll find out in our next willow movie
lot of willow talk hell yeah I thought
long and hard about this and I came back
to a film that just like really touched
me it's one of my favorite Disney films
of all time especially of recent years
wall-e and let's go visit wall-e and Eve
30 years later so they came back to
earth with the tree with the plant
they're on earth and they're bringing
people back and they're bringing the
planet back but by-and-large BNL is
basically terraforming the planet 30
years later smoke pumping gas guzzling
mega corporations are threatening to
destroy Earth and what they basically
kind of repopulated and regrew and it is
up to wall-e and Eve to stop this mega
corporation from destroying the planet
and taking everyone's Natural Resources
okay we got three cool choices fight it
out
I don't know how if you have visited
planet Earth lately but this sounds like
the most depressing movie ever I don't
how could we see while while he was a
hurt tearjerker and Hart pulling on the
heartstrings enough in the first place
but thirty years later are you actually
saying anything that is films have
taught us if there's anything that
Disney films has taught us it's okay to
be sad sometimes it's okay to have a
depressing story when a print when a
witch wants to kill a princess that's
kind of depressing so what you're saying
what you're saying is there's a great
villain here and it echoes in what's
going on today this
is a film this is a sequel whose message
would resonate way more because we are
destroying the planet as ridiculous as
an evil queen is a giant corporation is
even more faceless and scrubby than that
I mean Evil Queen at least he betweens
that personalities look at mirrors
literally faceless by definition there
would be an evil CEO why do we want to
go to this place I don't want to go to
this place okay what I like you could
say that about any what's fun about the
first wall new friends waters she's
riding on a bunch of tortoises wacko man
style Kiki are you riding whip aside and
you know I mean I'm gonna have childish
gambino in my son qualitatively but not
in sales I'm not interested in either of
these arguments anymore I'm interested
in this is I series okay let's think
about all of the Disney movie I thought
somebody might say that and so what I
would like to do is point all of you at
home how if you want to pull out your
phone for a second visit
disney.com know what you will see all
over disney.com Lucasfilm properties
called Star Wars and Marvel properties
so what I'm saying is if Star Wars and
Lucasfilm can make it onto the Disney
website then all of the other titles in
the Lucasfilm library are also included
I understand mine has actual like some
sort of cultural significance yours is a
fake hero time yours is a weird future
with with a bunch of fat people that are
one race I guess just a race of fat
people I would fit right in in that
future is one of the only features I can
see myself in
gulp future is my future I understand I
love it but look at the 30 years later
more on a story we get we get women
passing down a woman chieftain passing
down thanks to her to her to her
daughter and or granddaughter also we
would have we can have a nice in a Lucas
filming in fashion we can have a nice
Yoda ghost of her grandma to help to
help her out with the wit with the with
the with the with the Maui stuff where
we get Maui back we get our actual movie
star I think this movie my movie is only
one that has an actual movie star in it
alright all these movies my movies the
only one that has an actual movie star
that can actually open I'm gonna make
the game for good original fantasy
feature films we I was looking back
doing some research for this the 80s
were chock-full of original fantasy
properties and we are lacking in those
imaginative original fantasy properties
Willow was an a unique and really
exciting cool story that I thought is
not Disney from you know and you're
gonna be owned by Disney for a Disney
Channel show original fantasy features
that's what I want to dive into I I
doesn't have to just be on Game of
Thrones or it doesn't just have to be
Lord of the Rings like we can look at
these original fantasy feature film
properties and explore this mythology
and we can talk about you know I gotta
tell you I rewatched the original willow
and I think that it lays the groundwork
for the future of this franchise so well
sorsa is such an amazing incredible
character and I would love to see how a
Laura Dannon a princess grows up within
the realm it's this is Princess Leia
it's Wonder Woman like grows up I want
to tell you I want to go back and hit a
couple of things real quick you talk
about this
Wally being this potential sequel being
too depressing
have you seen up there's so many films
that deal in something dark and
depressing that are Disney centric
inside
okay um most people would disagree with
you because it's a beautiful film this
film not only would it venture into some
didactic territory it would also have an
impact on young people it would be a fun
rollicking tale of wall-e trying to save
the planet along with Eve but it would
it could also have an effect and that's
what Disney films do best
that's what inside-out I mean that made
me well up and I am a heartless bastard
inside out it's true that it's telling
kids that it's okay to be sad around you
can't film immoderately certain points
from you and from you first you said
original mythology and I love that you
said that that's super dope because you
want to know some original ass mythology
Polynesian and island peoples mythology
Tongan and and so on and so forth Samoan
basically you've got you got a surveyor
the God who rules over the land of the
dead torso of a human body of a giant
eel you got a knife wound or who's at
the God of War goddess of war strong as
whole armies of men these can be aligned
with the bad Islanders or the Mamas
people this is so awesome thirty years
later
it does not hit the mark for me with
Mona because Moana she is so young like
you said she's a teenager she has so
many stories and you want to cut to like
the end where she's passing down the
torch already where's the rest of Milan
also
Nolan took Batman's whole youth away in
other booty ass movies The Rock stole
Batman's you say nothing to know also
the rock is a terrible singer okay I am
sorry I am sorry my French I'm just
gonna break it under the very simple
things that are not emotional my movie
has an actual movie star okay that's it
it can actually open my movie can
actually open cuz it has a movie star
number two its services a market that
are still woefully underserved and that
as women heroes who aren't just these
Robo sex automatons who beat people up
and don't ever have any romantic
satisfaction ever because they got to be
strong all the time
this could be talking about passing down
the torch she's obviously got with a man
at some point and she doesn't issue that
you don't I mean and it's just part of
life and we don't have to make people so
so super strong that they never have any
emotional relationships or any familial
relationships we don't have to make all
women into like Trinity we can have we
can have Moana be a mother and a
grandmother and show that that it's
equally as strong as being a young woman
going out on adventure on her own with
no responsibilities we can show these
things in my movie and also service
diversity and all that jazz a Moana was
beautiful it was a beautiful world that
I would love to revisit was almost
avatar ask and in its beauty and where
you'd want to be I don't want to be in
your dank castle and I don't want to be
in your future box with the fatties I
don't I don't I want to be in Milan
island surfing all turtles and kicking
it with coconuts and being cool and
having adventures where crustacean armor
damnit armor but I want to go back to
the question the question is what movie
deserves a sequel thirty years later and
how I will say I love your argument
about Moana that's a great point Milan
is a child she has so much life and
discovery left to find why would we want
to flash-forward 30 years and miss out
on all of that but I also have to say
when it comes to wall-e once again I
don't want to see the world that wall-e
lives in 30 years later because if the
world that it's based on is in the
indication it ain't kind of
well what I want to see is I want to see
these heroes coming together and seeing
what they have been up to and and to
your point and about these female heroes
between sorsha and who Oh Laura Dannon
could become that's an arc that's a
mythology that's an untold legend and an
untold action-adventure story filled
with family and heart and creatures and
danger that I want to see now or other
there's no shortage of swords and
swashbuckling out there right now it's
you can there are so many movies and
there's so many TV shows if you talk
about Game of Thrones and all its
imitators also I am sad to say this and
I hate to say it but um I don't know if
Val Kilmer is in the shape to play mad
Mart again and you're not going to
replace that guy and also Edie kept
talking about the rock will open because
he's a movie star I mean is there are
people clamoring for Willow despite how
good the original movie is Edie you just
repeated the argument of the first movie
yes Moana is a wonderful Disney Princess
because you doesn't need a man to come
save her and she kicks major ass but
there are so many stories left to tell
um and you're saying while he's not
gonna open did you see Incredibles 2 and
how that opens so many years removed
that people love wall-e
it'll open and not only will this be a
great second of installment of the film
because thirty years later is enough
time for the earth to get effed after
they brought it back it'll be fun and
inspiring because they're going to save
the day we're going to give it a happy
ending it's not going to be a soul
destroying film it's gonna be like Toy
Story don't you know when Toy Story 3
they're not gonna end up going into the
furnace they're going to save the planet
okay and it's going to inspire kids and
teach them a good lesson that is pure
Disney all right time nice around you
guys real nice round I'm thinking on
this one
let's go to the facts real quick and
then we'll vote sure well first of all
Joe as a as a as an avid everyday
watcher jeopardy I hate to contradict
you but Alex Trebek does not attempted
it would also be the answers jeopardy
contestants have the question oh you
know what you just dig me real good the
facts no no friendships has no
boundaries when it comes to facts Geoff
and that's what I've always appreciate
about what is incorrect according to the
Disney wiki powered by fandom mallanna
is 16 years old so that is the
information that we have on her and
brought up the fact of the Dark Knight
Rises cutting out
Batman's youth or the Dark Knight
trilogy I should say and there has been
I've seen in a lot of the things that
I've read the resurgence one of the
things that I think a lot of people have
stated that they don't like about The
Dark Knight Rises is the fact that they
skipped over being Batman and he's
already at the end of his career so but
it is a it is a hotly debated topic I
would say and you know I mean it's all
down to preference but I'd say work
Davis is a movie star he isn't my heart
anyway and he's also been in like every
all of the most highest earning
franchise Estelle Jackson
so factually that's what I got for you
all right well you know another super
epic story were they they left the
character at 15 came back when he was
thirty Jesus that's just true that's in
the book that's in the book okay this
fight for me how they kept you on the
ropes they really they really just kept
you on the ropes sometimes they were
saying real arguments and sometimes they
were just saying words but either way
play and I haven't played a lot of
defense on that one so for me this came
down to ed and Clark both of those
closing arguments were really really
fantastic
I like the argument that Lord Dan and
the skip makes the most sense because
she's a baby now she's 30 and we want to
revisit those characters a lot my heart
really wants to go with Willow cuz also
I love that movie but I've got
give this point to add crustacean armor
that closing argument was just really
solid but even before the closing
argument what got me was the bullet
points on what we could still hit with
the mythology so my votes Edie I thought
that had that Hal got a little bit of
payback from the team up in the last
round actually because I thought that he
for me landed a knockout blow on Moana
by talking about how she's 16 years old
and you want to skip 30 years ahead to
the end of her story and you're missing
out on everything in the middle I
thought that was a really really good
argument against choice so that actually
knocked moe on out for me so look at me
it was between Howe and Clark and
between those two I felt like semantics
aside which again it was allowed on the
show so it's allowed to be argued I
think that Clark seemed much more
passionate and had a little bit more of
a clearer vision about not only what her
movie would be about but the different
spaces in the marketplace that it would
fill the enthusiasm I thought was really
there for it so I actually go with Clark
in Willow
all right we're 1-1 Daniel Radford the
voice of the people this was there was a
lot closer than you would have thought
46% for wall-e 29% for willow and 24%
going for more wanna so that's a vote
for how from the people that is yes so
that's that's a vote for for all three
of them yeah you're the host you break
the top Wow okay hmm okay I'm gonna sort
of try to take what you were talking
about a little bit into account to Dan
that pure you know facts aside arguments
aside I'll hit that sort of pure passion
argument and I'll give this to Willow
mark you'll take this round
thank you yes all right that's pretty
great we had some really good comments I
have to say what Billy said because it's
making me laugh Billy wrote in the chat
and I love that skip
the end of her story yep we all die at
46 we don't know what your Moana takes
place in what the life expectancy is in
that year no coconuts always falling who
knows I don't know I'd have to do some
research some other suggestions we got
where a lot of people wanted Roger
Rabbit to see what would happen with
more 3d characters bringing Joe's world
and also oh so many people want to see
Reilly from inside out have a full-on
midlife crisis that would be a very
heavy movie and now I'm just broken and
we're not gonna finish the show but not
yet not today all right guys let's hit
round three here shall we the Sandlot is
getting a prequel your question why
saying Lots getting a prequel guys kill
me Joe
pitch the most unnecessary pretty cool
you can think of for any movie Clarke
kick us off I would love to
so all right when it comes to
unnecessary prequels I think what makes
an unnecessary prequel is a dive into
mythology out of a perfect film really
or really substantial classic movies
it's like this is unnecessary why do we
need to know any more let's leave it
alone but the way Hollywood works says
that hey if we haven't tapped it yet oh
we got a dive in so I look to the Back
to the Future franchise now in a
franchise that is traveled decades
centuries even we've gone to the wild
wild west we've gone to the future we've
gone to the 50s where else could we go
Doc Brown prequel origin story ladies
and gentlemen let's look at the facts
here we have doc we know so much yet so
little about dr. Emmett Brown where did
he go to medical school
why are he and Marty such good friends
and why was he hanging rehanging a clock
that time that he
off the toilet and hit his head and came
up with the idea of the flux capacitor
we got an O with these answers we can't
we can't just leave these on mind
and so the Doc Brown prequel origin
story is the most unnecessary prequel
that I could ditch all right how run it
okay so I'm gonna pitch a movie that is
just a perfect little nugget and it
would be just a disemboweling of our
childhoods to go and make this prequel
it would be the prequel to Beetlejuice
Michael Keaton's performance in the
original Beetlejuice is just a thing of
beauty he's a just lightning in a bottle
so much fun I remember as a kid watching
that movie and like I just went nuts
over it's so good
so the terrible prequel would be Oh huh
who was Beetlejuice before he entered
purgatory who is this who is this a-hole
that ended up punished in the afterlife
and it would be a joyless slog through
this man's life following this jerk and
you don't have the characters of Lydia
you don't have her parents to offset
this this monster you need all of these
other characters and the the I'll save
it but yeah it would ruin something that
is a perfect little nugget all right ed
Grier well I think I'm gonna keep my
opening argument really short and sweet
the movie that I picked for super
unnecessary prequel and by my definition
the way I'm arguing this is movie that'd
be super boring and garbage it doesn't
add anything right and in that the
prequel to Pinocchio would be the worst
thing ever
it would probably literally be the story
of a tree kicking it in the woods
swaying in the breeze for about 50 years
until a lumberjack comes to chop sit
down
the end
that would basically be the movie so I'm
gonna leave it at that man that'd be the
worst prequel worse than these two
people that have lives at least the
prequel to Pinocchio not even alive yet
bro all right guys we have three garbage
fires Clark I would say like you're
fatally flawed right out of the gate
because Back to the Future has proven
that they can explore its own mythology
and they could go here there and
everywhere and have a great time one of
the great trilogies of all time I don't
care if like people like oh I don't know
and they're not all great movies they're
all fun movies that universe has proven
to be so much fun
more Doc Brown I feel like that's the
only palatable way to get back to the
future like because like a you know f
any kind of reboot or anything like that
or a remake of Back to the Future but
like Doc Brown's story
what did like how did he come to all
these contraptions and inventions it
doesn't make sense cuz Back to the
Future has been explored here they're
back again and it's work I actually
think it makes perfect sense because the
question was about unnecessary prequels
because we are looking at a movie like
the Sandlot and mining the things that
happen before the kids went to the
Sandlot with something like a Doc Brown
origin story who can play Doc Brown
that's not Christopher Lloyd so let's go
with me on this what we're gonna do what
we're gonna end up with the gang's all
gonna come back
but the mecca's is gonna come back and
you know what he's gonna do he's gonna
say I have all this technology I get D H
Christopher Lloyd and they're gonna put
Christopher Lloyd in weird suits and
it's gonna be bizarre and terrible and
only emphasize the fact that this is the
most unnecessary prequel of all time but
in addition to that unlike you're both
of your arguments mine actually could
probably get made and I think that's
what makes it scary and the most
unnecessary respond to that number one
mine could be made but then they do a
rewrite and it would be about
Gepetto's woodworking apprenticeship
should be arguably even more boring than
in tokyo being a tree so even if they
did make my movie it would be more still
to finally boring than yours because we
got we got time travel most likely got
we probably got an agent Marty McFly
having to come back and help Christopher
Lloyd do something to make sure that his
invention of the time machines actually
happens to make the whole story happen
which is super kind of cool and and
yours you said it would disavow your
childhood in all this jazz to see
somebody try to reprise beetlejuice deal
with D aging technology and with the
iconic nature of the performance in that
I've seen pretty decent beetle juices at
every whorehouse little thing I've ever
gone to they put a bunch of makeup on
they go crash somebody had to do that to
fill things that be perfectly fine you
know what I say I think that could be
done for Doc Brown perhaps not for Mike
Adams beetle be fun his his trials and
tribulations of finding time travel
juice Michael Keaton's Beetlejuice there
is no more iconic character from the
eighties practically is a good story he
was driven to suicide he used to work in
the in as an apprentice to that to that
lady Juno and in this in the office he
got cursed out of everything because he
actually committed suicide and I ruined
his afterlife so he's got how did that
happen a new Joker movie that's always
more interesting than that stupid new
Joker movie right if the biz that it is
um you picked just a comically boring
idea the most boring prequel but that
was cricket what back Geppetto what
about the the Blue Angel you know okay I
can argue unnecessary to let's get down
like the prison with you
as far as unnecessary it's unnecessary
because there aren't any magic elements
available so it would be just about
woodworking and and the nature of the
medium and stuff like that and I'm sure
some dumb executive could maybe have a
piece of wood that Geppetto touched our
quiver and the background or something
to give you some stupid inkling that his
powers are kicking in and you know
something of that nature they could
definitely make this move it could
definitely suck but the reason why it's
unnecessary is it doesn't have anything
to do with the theme of the first movie
which is life from nothing unnecessary
it's because it wouldn't have the magic
of the first one and that is because the
lightning in the bottle that was 1980s
to early mid-90s Tim Burton Tim Burton
at that time Edward Scissorhands
pee-wee's big adventure Beetlejuice and
would just what an amazing run he had
and that he hasn't recaptured it since
he hasn't come close to it he's kind of
sold out and he's making these kind of
by the numbers he's become a little bit
of a dare I say Ron Howard for his
studio yeah for his work but the unique
vision of Beetlejuice where it turns
into a carnival what Otho tries to run
and he puts the Leisure Suit on him
there are so many beautiful touches that
you couldn't go back to also Beetlejuice
a little bit of a problematic guy how
are you going to be able to see young
Beetlejuice when you have to take the
teeth out of we're in the grand age of
trying to demystify evil old white dudes
like trying to try to get back to what
happened to you because there's always
some reason when it's an evil old white
dude there's always some reason with
other people they're just evil but when
it's all white when it's a evil white
dude what happened to you what trauma
caused you to be such a piece of garbage
and that's what they would love to
explore with beetlejuice to go back to
see what drove him to suicide to go back
to see why he has this unique
relationship with the afterlife
I'm not totally sold on like the evil
old white
job is literally an evil old white dude
what are we talking about we want to go
see his origin because it's interesting
to see how he got to where he got the
beetlejuice you're a definition an evil
sort of creepy guy you're kind of
seconding my argument because it's like
oh we're already kind of getting a story
like that with the joke like yeah this
is very unnecessary thank you Clark take
us home all right at the end of the day
what I think makes an unnecessary
prequel is the fact that we already know
the story and we've back to the future I
would argue there is nothing else that
we need to see three movies so many
timelines and at the end of the day we
already know the context of the
information with Doc and with Marty some
things are better left unsaid and so at
the end of the day if there were to be a
Back to the Future Doc Brown origin
story prequel I don't know how that is
not the definition of unnecessary when
we already know most of this information
through lines of dialogue that has been
delivered through the trilogy all right
now any closing thoughts yeah sure dude
what if you didn't you know what the
defense rests
yeah like I said the Back to the Future
universe has been explored with three
movies that were so much fun if you kept
it Canon and did not do like a full-on
like reboot to kind of just ruin
everything and make a bad version of a
good movie that could be a lot of fun
and that's worth exploring with
Pinocchio they're compelling characters
they're compelling stories just the the
spells that bring a wooden child to life
seeing that again and going in and
getting one a modern telling a modern
take on a classic tale that would
actually be kind of fascinating to me
but taking a great performance taking
one of the great movies from a director
who had an epic almost unparalleled run
Tim Burton from the 80s to the 90s and
taking the joy out of it taking the
components out of it
the the visual style of that movie when
Nonna riders just yn2 Michael Keaton's
yang there's so much that just makes
this specific movie work to go back and
follow beetlejuice in some other story
with a different actor god forbid a
soul-crushing career like all I have to
say is in in both of the other two
movies I can certainly see how I don't
really see how they get made because III
do want to know what happens what
happened to make the Iranians get so mad
I do fully apologize for that miss pica
to everyone involved all you nerds and
now the people who are really affected
by things like that what I do say that
like there are to me there are stories
that could be told about young Doc Brown
and how he came to time machine
technology one of the things about the
the guys who invented Superman one of
them had a relative or a brother or
something that got shot and so they
invented a bulletproof character well
what happens to you that makes you want
to invent time travel what trauma
happens to you to make you want to
invent time travel to go back a percent
for offense such a thing I could see an
a viable story being made out of that I
could also see a viable story being made
out of you know again a person who in
life was probably a smooth talker and a
cool guy but now he's in this constant
underworld where nobody trusts him
nobody wants to nobody wants to deal
with him how does one go for being a
smooth talker cool guy that's alive to
the ultimate pariah of the dead I could
see that being an interesting story but
man chilling out for 20 minutes of wood
carving montages it would be brutal it
would be totally unnecessary because
we're talking about unnecessary by
definition is something that doesn't
need to be and guess what you don't need
to know homeboys woodworking skills you
don't need to know where the enchanted
wood came from you don't need to know
what Jiminy Cricket it to him he was
kicking it in a lily pad
whatever bugs do it to the wood boy came
that's what he was doing what who cares
I just show the greatest
counter-argument ever and I am taking
myself let's breathe disco yeah baby I
just now want you to write TV Guide
loglines Dan what are the facts
oh so many facts my one fact by big fact
check was done by Clarke so factually
accurate okay
so and I think I think this round you
were really hoping for a mic drop on
it's about a tree and I needed a little
more from you on on that so this was
between Hal and Clarke for me and how
early kicked this one off in the in the
opening and no one ever really kicked
you didn't ever really kick him back for
it
the idea that Back to the Future has fun
playing with its own mythology and being
very meta so it can explore those stupid
trivial things that in maybe a Star Wars
setting might refer to trivial solo but
in the Back to the Future movie can be
grounds for some fun and shenanigans and
then just the sentence oh and then you
twisted that Joker counter really well
the fact that this makes it even more on
this is air because we're getting the
Joker movie and then just the sentence
what about Jiminy Cricket which you said
like admits it so thank you Dan I think
sometimes movie fights is about what is
sad and sometimes we fight is about
what's not said and I'd literally
pitched a movie that was alternatively
about a tree growing in the forest or a
guy working in a wood shop as an
apprentice and nobody liked how like
sort of challenged him on a bit at the
end but like other than that it was all
Doc Brown Beetlejuice crossfire and Edie
by the way I thought had great arguments
to both of them about what could be made
of a compelling movie and I like I mean
he pitched a movie about a tree growing
in the forest that's the most
unnecessary in my life I have to go with
I have to get was played by Nick
Offerman
you [ __ ] Joe but just in the house chair
today Danielle the people need to save
us well the people are going
Pinnochio 48% Betelgeuse 28% and back to
the future with 23% I there were some
really good pitches on Twitter one of
them was by at forensic chick underscore
chicks CH I K most unnecessary prequel
before the original Ghostbusters just
watchin Egon Venkman and Spangler
performing research at the University
none of the experiments work taking
notes filling out grant applications
[Applause]
another really good one that I liked was
at chainsaw cat 19 we do not need a
prequel to Jaws it's just a town that's
been having a chill you know what my did
the couch or even I'm kicking myself for
what drives a man to want to make a
little boy what loss
yeah like was Geppetto cursed with like
impotence by a witch that he already had
I didn't know there there was this much
energy for Geppetto knowledge I think I
think we're onto something I think we're
on to some kind of zeitgeist but
meanwhile Edie you get the point that
was brutal bad did you mean that was
great
Adam Clark you will be going into the
speed round how Rudnick's sir that was a
hell of a fight uh you know what I left
it all in the field so feel good man
hopeful real good you know what um hey I
feel nothing no man what about Jiminy
Cricket yeah did say that like you did
that was great okay so we'll be going
into the speed round he'll be checking
in with you with your for your thoughts
but then Daniel you're losing the will
of the people in this one cuz we got to
get moving cuz it's the speed round am I
saying that correctly I don't know they
just put me in the chair didn't tell me
other show works correctly now I have my
own opinions and I hate it perfect
alright guys first speed round again
player needs a total of four points so
ed you need two more points Clark you
need a slightly more math amount of
points to beat Edie same rules as
applies before as they always have
whoever answers first will respond first
you get 20 seconds twenty seconds ten
seconds ten seconds you guys have done
this before you're old you're old hands
at the old speed round question number
one movie pass remains defiant in the
face of its financial troubles what
movie would you never watch again even
for free Max Payne with Mark Wahlberg
hmm
[Music]
do I start now or do no II don't
mm-hmm
this is horrible radio I'm dying
not a film ten more seconds buddy okay
[Music]
it's an empty threat I don't know what
happened no add finding Forrester Dan's
on time and you were going ahead with
Max Payne all right so uh Max Payne I
went and saw on the worst date of my
life that was the only date that Max
Payne is boring it's derivative its
joyless and god it's just Mark Wahlberg
and Mila Kunis being weird for an entire
movie plus another video game adaptation
that does not work Max Payne is one of
the worst movies I've ever seen I've
found finding Forrester to be so
pedantic and stupid and and white savory
in the worst way and and and and what
savory in the way where it's like you
saved the kids but they save you to like
all put a gun in my mouth you're a man
now dog all that stuff just just the the
reclusive writer stereotype the black
athlete stereotype who happens to be
able to string sentences together
oh how surprising more all right well I
can't argue that but well I can't argue
is that Max Payne is a piece of garbage
he's never been made in the first place
the visuals were terrible the action
sucked it was joyless once again and
terrible performances from good actors
across the board I also found it to be
Max Payne was a garbage video game
adaptation but finding Forrester was a
Gus Van Sant's movie after Good Will
Hunting all talk about a cliff bro
alright watch me discover how the speed
round works in real time Dan are there
any facts
no no fact checking the speed round hey
yeah it's all fiction and garbage Dan
would you vote for ma'am do you have a
vote in the speed round I'm falling
apart that's the fun of me yeah that
it's very difficult they both seem to
hate both of those movies a lot I've got
to go with sheer volume not loudness but
number of things on this I suppose it so
I would go with Clarke III think between
the two okay solid you know after a
solid Sean Connery impression aside yeah
I got it I got to go sheer volume on
that guy to that point goes to Clarke
you are not yet around question number 2
2001 a Space Odyssey is coming to IMAX
and Rebecca Ferguson was just casting
the sequel to The Shining what is the
best Stanley Kubrick movie The Shining
Full Metal Jacket
alright so the shining is a movie that
not only is is now critically it revered
but it also it features great
performances it's a movie that stands on
its own it's very separate from the
source material but it is truly
Kubrick's take on an iconic story where
he was able to make that iconic story
iconic in his own way well that's just
the thing he did take something that was
super great on its own and made his own
kind of twisted very popular but twisted
version of it whereas said that Kubrick
worked with directly with the
screenwriter a lot to craft the story of
Full Metal Jacket it's even broken down
into two axed one one act is boosts base
camp or boot camp
and the other one is the actual war I
found that to be a tremendous device if
you have read the book The Shining which
I have it is Stanley Kubrick's The
Shining basically only shares the name
Torrance in common it is truly Stanley
Kubrick's movie and that is why it is
his greatest movie it doesn't even need
the source material I would argue that
coming into a genre as packed as Vietnam
movies and making one of the standout
ones to my mind the standout one it is a
remarkable achievement by a person
especially later in life I can't believe
no one said Eyes Wide Shut ten seconds
on high highs one shot go oh there's so
much nudity we definitely go back to
entitle an episode after because God you
know I thought the the the interesting
thing on this one was you guys sort of
go having an adaptation battle which I
thought was really interesting the the
argument that he took something
completely and and made it his own
versus ed getting into a couple more
specifics about you know sort of being a
standout Vietnam War movie and then
talking about the time split device a
little bit I'm gonna give this one to Ed
Dan I thought ed made a very salient
counter-argument against Clark about
taking something that was already
popular and and just sort of co-opting
it but I thought Clark came back very
well with the fact that it made shares
the Nate's here's the title and
character names but that it was very
undeniably Kubrick so I think that she
fought back well and I'm gonna go with
Clark on this okay
that means Danielle you have to decide
who's not gonna be your friend anymore
secondly I am again both really really
good arguments I do have to say I agree
with Dan I do think that I
I found Clark's argument to be more
compelling so I'm going with Clark
don't kill me yet all right point goes
to Clark Joe if I can just recommend if
you any of you out there haven't seen
Stanley Kubrick's The Killing it's one
of the best film Noirs I want him it
might be my favorite Kubrick film the
killing from like 1957 59 something like
that when are we finally gonna do our
Eyes Wide Shut podcast because I've been
hassling you about this for decades oh
yeah let's make it happen
yeah okay maybe phantom will give us a
little bit of budget for our eyes watch
yes I'm really excited about it a mask
oh I don't let anyone Clark game point
for you Ed you gotta take this one to
stay in the ball game and it is a man if
you thought Kubrick was a big question
for the speed round who would you rather
kiss better more penny wise penny wise
[Laughter]
okay let's hear clearly first of all the
Internet agrees with me because the
Internet is shipping penny wise all over
the place but for my own personal taste
penny wise is tall he's young he's sassy
pants and boy does he open his mouth and
make out with a kiss because that's the
question that's really hard to make out
with somebody when you're trembling in
super fear of them whereas you know I
know good old Eddie and we have a good
rapport and he gets that to get that
black suit on you know and he gets that
tongue working that venom tongue is an
iconic comic book tongue it's the gene
Simmons of the Marvel and he just he
just he works it around and I know it
feel good and and it's an alien
life-form I'm gauging with alien life
I think at the end of the day this all
comes down to preference you are talking
about a lot tongue action but paralyzed
rules he's got a lot of he's got a lot
of moisture there he's got Reese got
like a lot of jaw action so for me I
want to make out with that guy yeah but
I'm only gonna deal with the one row of
teeth I feel like Pennywise has multiple
rows of teeth depending on how scary
he's trying to be at the point to eat
your fear and I think he'd be poking you
while he's kissing you to make you
scared so you can eat and kiss at the
same time whereas you know when I'm sad
I wasn't hosting when like this is why I
like screen cookies honestly you guys
cuz we can start with some big games gun
conversation at the top of the show yeah
and then make our way here so really
this came down to moisture versus rows
of teeth for me and man you know we've
got the I think it was it was a ding
against you the gene Simmons tongue of
the Marvel Universe because then that
made me think of kissing gene Simmons
which I don't want to do necessarily so
I got it I got my vote is Clark dan you
both took it so personally which I love
yeah way to fight in form
let's put it over the top from kissing
okay I didn't Clark you kind of suck
yourself with a lot of moisture personal
preference baby I find that it's
typically you know unless you're doing
that scene from cruel intention no one
wants you picked right even though we
both want to do both one but ed gets the
point they're a public one
I appreciated most that you guys were
both in very like committed consensual
relationships with a wise and Venom
there was a little background on each
and I really appreciated that hey guys
let's find a winner to this sucker The
Daily Beast recently ran a story about
an ex-cop who you guys hear about this
allegedly stole over 24 million dollars
from the McDonald's Monopoly game and
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck have already
optioned it for a movie what other
ridiculous bonkers news story deserves
big-screen treatment Oh stormy Daniels
okay big crazy story I'm gonna this is
what we call a callback Lord and Miller
being fired from Han Solo all right
okay what did I say no okay stormy
Daniels number one it's a great part for
an actress you know we love these great
parts for actresses you have almost
every line in the movie should be in
almost every scene we could talk about
the Madonna and a horror complex that
this country has the fact that we shunt
people off into little boxes the fact
that she's supposedly just some hooker
but she has the access to all the halls
of power she's gonna bring down a
president conceivably what we what we
love as audience members is behind the
scenes Hollywood stories we like to see
the true gossip that we see on the big
screen and it is a tale of failure it is
a tale of success it is a tale of
trouble and it is a tale of corporate
greed and too big to fail except with
movies and our favorite of franchise
characters I see this movie as a
combination between like a Erin
Brockovich and all the President's Men
you know I mean just just a real Crewson
who is forced into a crusade because of
the evil what's wrong with your stories
we don't know how it ends yet so at the
end of the day this could be all for
naught he could get away with it and
nobody wants to see that movie
[Music]
Brockovich and all the President's Men
if it goes that way no guarantee Clarke
very confident left those four seconds
on the board Dan hmm you got some
thoughts yeah I think that it came it
came down to it's very mm it's very
difficult came down to Clarke Annette
for me and the game of inches I'm gonna
have to give it to the clerk to bring up
a get that point which is that we don't
know how the story ends and it may not
make for a good Hollywood story either
way you just don't know if it's gonna be
a satisfying conclusion so I'm gonna go
with Clarke on this one okay all right
okay so this one again was a sort of a
rule of moisture versus rodent teeth for
me you're gonna start saying that
although yeah
hey terrible line both you guys had
amazing opening arguments I thought both
of those are absolutely fantastic when
it came down to for me were the
rebuttals and sometimes in movie fights
it's just about getting those specifics
and Edie painted a really good picture
with that Erin Brockovich versus all the
President's Men
and Clark much like I think the the the
the tree mic drop I think you sort of
tried to sort of drop a little
prematurely on the story isn't over so I
got a vote for Edie Danielle we're
stressing you out a little bit again
there you all it all comes down to
Daniel rat fur so yeah this is both of
these arguments were absolutely great I
know you said that Jo said that you
thought it wasn't a mic drop movie a
moment I thought it was a mic drop
moment I'm just saying cuz we don't know
how that how it ends and this could all
end in a fizzle and then that doesn't
make for great movie unless you have to
like make something up or make up an
ending and so for me that push it over
to Clark all right Clark you take the
round which means
[Applause]
hell of a fight guys we covered a lot of
ground it down made out with monsters
both of us yeah voluntarily I guess we
covered some terrible prequel ideas of
Dec of a show oh how you feeling oh
pretty good pretty good back in the ring
oh man it was super fun I uh you know I
you know had fun fighting against these
two they really brought it and you know
what I yeah what can I say it's nicely
done thank you for for steering the ship
amiably and with a deft hand we're all
about to crash dance thank you guys so
much for doing what you did of course
thank you so much also I do have to
mention one person for a movie based off
of a headline said they should do a
movie about the fire festival and and
Lonely Island should produce it yes yes
that is the right answer I think we
should do a movie about hand mom anyone
remember tab pan mom hashtag never
forget also just want to throw in our
follow me on instagram at Hal Rudnick
I'm posting a lot of asking a lot of
dopey movie questions on there and on
twitter at hal rudra and if you live in
the Southern California area I believe
you're running up on the 10th
anniversary of a little thing you
created called the tournament of nerds
oh heck yeah on Saturday August 18th the
tournament and nerds which a lot of
people in this room have been a part of
and I would love to have more of the
people in the room haven't been a part
of it be a part of it yeah Joe star is
always hilarious whenever he does the
tournament nerds comedy debate show at
The Upright Citizens Brigade in Los
Angeles midnight Saturday August 18 one
of my favorite things ten years
congratulating so that's a rare thing in
this town ten years of that show Ed
Greer my dear friend where can people
find you on the Internet
first of all great battle that was super
awesome I want to show humility and
defeat also follow me at a Ed Grier
destroys on Instagram and all the other
socials you know Twitter all that and
please check out my podcast in the Nerd
goat podcast it's definitely a
time it's a deep dive on people's
favorite characters their nerd greatest
of all time that's the so it's like we
talk to people about you know why you
like X fictional character and it gets
deep and there's there's a real
psychological journey it's good listen
and we're five-star rated baby yeah
check that out in this town rare thing
Clark Wolfe congratulations on the win
thank you
where can people find John you can find
me at clark will clark with an e wolf of
the knee and you can find me at fandom
with these guys doing all sorts of fun
cool entertainment stuff and thank you
guys for having me this was super super
fun i had a great time absolutely know
this is a fantastic show dance thank you
guys so much
billy in the booth jte you guys for
watching at home thanks for joining us
we will see you next week as how redneck
says bye bye
you